it may look a bit ungainly but this car
isn't trying to win a beauty contest
it's powered by hydrogen gas pumped into
the car right here there are just 300
cars like this in the whole of Germany
currently Toyota and Hyundai are the
only manufacturers to offer them here
according to Sevilla he / she works for
a company that promotes hydrogen fuel
infrastructure today she's taking us on
a test spin through Hamburg you'll have
to give it a try and get behind the
wheel I wouldn't say no yeah that's what
I figured it belongs to the company I
work for h2 mobility but in fact I've
just ordered my cell phone no it's not
with the help of government incentives
you can lease a car like this for about
600 euros a month that's across turd and
it would cost about 75 thousand euros to
buy one that's a list price seventy five
thousand euros would normally get you a
luxury model so it's no surprise that
Toyota lease is most of its hydrogen
fuel vehicles the car maker is hoping to
win over Germans to the idea of hydrogen
powered emissions free vehicles we're
about to go into a tunnel no idea we're
going north or south South under the
Elbe River so not to Italy we could that
would be no problem with hydrogen fuel
on our app you can even see where you
can get fuel I'll be taking my own Mirai
on a ski holiday later this month we'll
get fuel in Innsbruck and we could also
fill up in bolts on all these days
international travel with a hydrogen
powered car is no problem amazing isn't
it
Sybilla Lepus company h2 mobility is
working to expand the network of fueling
stations for hydrogen cars the startup
is based in Berlin and receives funding
from the German government and industry
partners the fueling stations cost about
1 million euros each
so does building them even make economic
sense they are as its orders markets
always grow in parallel in other words
infrastructure and consumer numbers go
hand in hand infrastructure has to be a
step ahead or take the first step will
have 100 fueling stations built by 2019
and we're seeing the number of cars and
vehicle fleets grow accordingly it
currently Germany has just 41 hydrogen
fuel filling stations like this one in
Hamburg total and shale are two of the
companies involved in h2 mobility along
with diesel and gasoline they also offer
hydrogen fuel it's sold by weight not
volume here it costs 9 euros 50 per kilo
I've arranged to talk to a customer how
much did he get two point two kilos just
under 21 years how far can you drive on
those 2 kilos like yeah I just made
about 200 kilometres give or take I
looking to meet all my family I think so
about a hundred kilometres a kilo all
shocked about that but it can vary now
it's my turn
Pizza thank you sir
this will be interesting
we're insured yes you were kind enough
to sign a liability agreement of course
you signed one stop cut yeah I want to
know when I can finally push the power
mode let's wait until we stop at a light
then you'll really notice the
acceleration when it turns green we'll
see here we come here we go hey what
happens if I now crash into a car will
we blow up because of all the hydrogen
on board put the endodermis toffee in
the model something people are worried
about hydrogen is so light that it
immediately dissipates if you have a
crash if you have an accident with a
gasoline-powered vehicle the gasoline
can leak onto the ground
it remains flammable for some time
afterwards but hydrogen is lighter than
air so it disperses in the air like that
it's wolf distance or 40 Cal flue
I managed to avoid crushing the car just
as well given its price and rarity
civility / hopes we'll be seeing more
hydrogen powered cars in the future
Mercedes is set to launch the world's
first plug-in hydrogen vehicle later
this year